uh interestingly the obi-wan kenobi your
braid
that you wore in the first films it was
recently up for auction
now it doesn't it looks slightly less
impressive not attached to your head
this is this is how it appeared in the
auction cap
now good game good game shirley ballas
how much did that braid of hair go for
50 000 okay oh how much
don't you no you can't answer yet don't
have to oh yeah uh ashley what do you
think oh um 51 000.
okay uh frank you are a star wars fan
how much would you pay for i am and i
don't want to go lower in case you and
he's deeply offended i'm gonna say
28 grand yeah i went for three uh
no not three dollars three thousand
three thousand
i would say that would have been three
dollars would have been really rude no
three thousand
i was thinking what i would pay oh yeah
all right uh euro mcgregor it's uh
lovely thank you for taking time out of
your filming to come and talk to us
and uh hopefully we'll see you soon
[Music]
you